В ІТ-експертів - погані новини для уряду Німеччини.
Якщо хакери змогли проникнути до інформаційної мережі IVBB,
якою користуються всі німецькі міністерства,
то, скоріш за все, вони зламали
не лише німецькі міноборони й МЗС, а й решту відомств.
У тому числі відомство федерального канцлера,
упевнені експерти з кібербезпеки.
Скоріш за все проникли скрізь. Якщо це загальна мережа,
якщо вона навіть адмініструється якимось загальним чином,
то, як правило, компроментується ціла мережа.
Німецькі спецслужби виявили атаку в грудні 2017 року.
Причому, судячи з усього, вона тривала цілий рік.
Протягом цього часу хакери господарювали в урядовій мережі:
викрадали документи й підкидали віруси.
Єдина добра новина полягає в тому, що в цій мережі
навряд чи зберігались особливо таємні документи німецького уряду.
Секретні дані, як правило, перебувають на спеціальних серверах,
відокремлених від інтернету, пояснюють експерти.
Цілком таємні дані повинні оброблятися лише
на спеціальних ОЕВМ - ізольованих.
Якщо десь і є доступ до інтернету, в тому числі комп‘ютерів,
які можна легко заразити, то, як правило,
там містяться максимум якісь дані для службового користування.
Звичайно, може бути й певна службова таємниця,
але навряд чи щось грандіозне.
Утім, сам факт цього нападу шокував Німеччину.
Про хакерську атаку повідомили практично всі провідні ЗМІ,
а багато німецьких політиків - особливо опозиційних -
обурені мовчанням спецслужб.
За їхніми словами, впродовж цілого минулого року
на брифінгах про розвідку їм жодного разу не повідомляли про цю атаку,
хоч спецслужби, ймовірно, вже знали про неї.
Тепер політики вимагають роз‘яснень.
Нині ми бачимо, що Німеччина явно не підготовлена до кібератак.
По-іншому це не можна тлумачити,
якщо російські хакери вільно проникають
у мережу міноборони й МЗС.
Те, що атаку здійснили саме російські хакери,
технічно довести складно, оскільки вони не залишили відповідних слідів,
заявили експерти. Однак
джерела в німецьких спецслужбах упевнені, що йдеться саме про хакерів,
пов‘язаних з російським урядом. Раніше, судячи з усього,
те ж угруповання ATP28-Fancy Bear атаковало
еякі уряди в Європі, демократичну партію США,
Міжнародний олімпійський комітет і Всесвітню антидопінгову агенцію.